Here in Los Angeles,
COVID vaccines are being slowly
distributed to people 65 and older.
But according to a recent article,
some people under 65 in L.A.
are still trying to get
the vaccine at any cost.
These people are being
called vaccine chasers.
Yeah.
Now, typically these people
line up at vaccination sites
for hours, hoping there
might be an extra dose
available at the end of the day.
Not only that, since this is L.A.,
some of these people are
going as far as sending in
audition tapes to be considered
for early vaccination.
Yeah, we actually got our hands
on some of these vaccine audition tapes.
Yeah, unbelievable, check them out.
Hi, Jocelyn Marks, Stewart Talent,
and I am auditioning to get a vaccine.
(gasps)
(moans)
(groans)
Hi, I'm Jeff Matthews and I'm
auditioning for the vaccine
with some of my impressions.
So you want the vaccine?
You can't handle the vaccine!
Hi, Danny Richardson, SAG-eligible.
No, I'm not technically a doctor.
I did play one once in
a small, adult film.
Eli Bright, special
skill: stand-up comedy.
You know, men and women
get COVID very differently.
So I actually brought some wigs.
They're from my improv
studio before it burnt down.
Oh, this one's cool.
It's kinda like...
No, you know what?
I'm so sorry.
Slate, hi, my name is
Barry Diesel, no relation.
This is my first video audition.
I am a stage combat expert,
proficient in such styles as punching,
staff work,
(staff clatters)
swordplay,
and throwing a banana in slow motion.
(banana thuds)
Hi, I'm Kathy Yamamoto.
Please give me the vaccine.
(pounding on door)
(child screaming)
Sorry.
Sorry, I'm doing an audition.
[Child] We're hungry!
Can you just keep it down?
[Child] Mommy, you never feed us!
Roommates. (laughs)
And I, they let me keep the lab coat,
which is pretty great, right?
Also I will do nudity.
Wow, ow, wow!
White people take the vaccine like this.
Allrighty then.